Did Queen Elizabeth II hate-watch The
Crown?! Apparently she was a regular viewer,
even if she detested how one character
was portrayed. And no, it wasn't her!
In addition to receiving numerous awards
for its cast, costumes, and effects,
Netflix's The Crown has earned its share
of criticisms, particularly regarding its
relationship to real-life history. The series
focuses on the lives of the royal family,
starting when Queen Elizabeth II unexpectedly
becomes Queen at the young age of 25.
"But for better or worse, the
crown has landed on my head."
While its individual storylines are derived from
actual events, much of the show is embellished,
consisting of fictionalized accounts of
conversations and interactions that may or
may not have actually happened. At one point, the
United Kingdom's culture secretary, Oliver Dowden,
said that The Crown should add a fiction
disclaimer. Dowden told The Mail on Sunday,
"I fear a generation of viewers who did not live
through these events may
mistake fiction for fact."
While both Netflix and The Crown
creator Peter Morgan have stated
they believe audiences to be smart enough
to figure out that the show is, in fact,
fiction, this sentiment is not shared by
all relevant parties. Helena Bonham Carter,
who portrays Princess Margaret in Seasons 3
and 4, told the official podcast for the show:
"['The Crown'] is dramatized. I do
feel very strongly because I think
we have a moral responsibility to say, 'Hang
on guys, this is not ... it's not a drama-doc,
we're making a drama.' So there
are two different entities."
While many royals have made it clear
they aren't fans of Netflix's The Crown,
the late Queen Elizabeth II expressed that she was
most upset about how Prince Philip was portrayed
as a callous and insensitive father to Prince
Charles. A senior royal source told Express:
"She was particularly annoyed at a
scene in which Philip has no sympathy
for a plainly upset Charles while he
is flying him home from Scotland."
In Season 2, Episode 9, Prince Philip flies a
clearly upset Prince Charles home from Gordonstoun
after Charles attempts, and fails, to participate
in a school challenge. As Philip tries to tell
Charles how he did during the challenge is of no
consequence to him, Charles looks frightened and
anxious as they fly through turbulence. Philips
continues with his pep talk, telling Charles,
"It's just air."
Phillip then tells his son
that he's weak and orders
him to the back of the plane. The
senior royal source told Express:
"That simply did not happen."
Despite her distaste for the way The Crown
depicts Prince Philip's relationship with
a young Prince Charles, it's since been
publicly revealed that Queen Elizabeth II,
did, in fact, regularly
watch The Crown on Netflix.
A report by Entertainment Weekly recounts how,
during a broadcast of the Queen's funeral,
leading royal authority George Jobson happened
to mention that Queen Elizabeth II once made a
habit of watching The Crown on Sundays.
He even brought up the fact that Prince
Philip would sometimes discourage his wife
from tuning in, knowing that it would make
her upset. This latter detail suggests that the
relationship between Prince Philip and Prince
Charles might not have been the Queen's only
gripe with the show, but rather one of many.
Given that it mines their real lives for drama,
it's no surprise that members of the royal family
may have taken issue with some of the contents of
The Crown. Of course, while series creator Peter
Morgan has stated he plans to make at least
six seasons, whether or not Queen Elizabeth
II's passing affects the show's future could
remain a point of interest moving forward.